my man
how much pressure is it to get this
thing exactly right we know you've been
working on this passion project for ages
and ages and ages and the fans just ate
it up today
they did eat it up today today was a
dream come true hall h6 6 000 fans like
that man showing up as black adam
but
yeah there's a lot of pressure to get it
right
but also i just i knew we all knew very
early on the opportunity that we had we
have an opportunity here to create a
character that has never been seen
before on the big screen has never been
exposed to the world you got to come
with it uh hopefully you don't screw it
up um and you got to make sure that you
surround yourself with the best
filmmakers but also the ambition was to
do something that's never been done
before and that's tough to do uh
considering the genre of superheroes but
um i think we've made a great movie and
it's a character that people are excited
to see
you could feel the momentum building you
could start to feel a shift
um i've been saying you know the
hierarchy of power in the dc universe is
about to change
um and it will
based on that character but also
probably more importantly what you're
going to find is just ushering a new era
in to the dc universe i love
i've been at dc
from birth dc boy now i'm a dc bigger
boy still a boy
but you could start to feel some really
nice momentum and just a shift in
ushering a new anti-hero era
into the dc universe and i'll end this
the only way i know how the most
appropriate way love you
you